okay the david pakman show reddit
discussion forum is really growing
almost 4000 of our viewers and listeners
now regularly discussing politics there
every day we have had some great
feedback to recent segments on the show
you can find the forum at david
pakman.com slash reddit let's look at
just some of the interesting posts and
stories that are up on the reddit
discussion forum as of this morning
starting with a very very interesting
almost like a de facto reddit ask me
anything from a transgender Navy veteran
who went on our reddit discussion forum
and said hey in light of everything that
Trump is doing banning transgender
servicemembers I'm a transgender a
veteran ask me questions any questions
I'm glad to answer and that has been a
super interesting thread so far Pat even
though I don't necessarily agree with
everything that's being said I would
encourage our audience to check that out
because it's super interesting
perspective also on the David Pakman
show right a discussion forum Trump in
sessions no longer speaking to one
another according to a recent report
from the hill interesting conversation
about that also on the reddit discussion
forum isn't a thirty-eight percent
approval rating shockingly high and this
is a this is something I've been saying
for a while
despite record low approval ratings for
Trump at this point in his presidency
I'm shocked that you can randomly survey
three people in the United States and at
least one of them statistically is going
to say I approve of the job Trump is
doing I completely agree with this idea
how does nearly 40% of the population
support what we're seeing this
interesting too because you compare that
to george w bush's lo which was maybe
the high twenty twenty eight percent or
not at this point in his presidency when
your presidency but it's I think it's
because Trump seems to have this cult
following and the personality of sorts
and Bush never really had that yeah
that's true that's true
and also many discussions on the reddit
discussion forum about the Dave Rubin
interview Dave Rubin interview was great
as one viewer and many many discussions
related to that another reddit goer
saying David Rubin is a straight-up
libertarian and that was not a rare
reaction Pat many people saying yeah he
really struck me more as a straight-up
libertarian than as a
classical liberal and you know at this
point political definitions are sort of
a hazy thing anyway people have been
trying to tell Dave Rubin he's a
libertarian for a long time and I mean
the difference is though between
libertarianism and classical liberalism
are kind of in the weeds it's not too
big of a difference yeah no I totally
agree with that on a lot of issues
that's absolutely the case so anyway
join the discussion at david pakman.com
slash read it app at frequents the
reddit I frequent the reddit a lot of
interesting stuff people curious we
didn't get to this but people curious on
the reddit they want pictures of your
cold brew coffee brewing setup people
very curious about that and every
everything that's happening at Pats
place which is increasingly alarming to
some but you can't tell you everything
that goes on now I know I know I know
but anyway
join the discussion there